fait quand même penser à une vous Marine
Le Pen parlait d'un d'un gouvernement
d'union nationale donc dans un
gouvernement de l'Union nationale on
pourrait imaginer peut-être que Zemmour
et sa place je crois qu'il en a pas très
envie de gouvernement
et je vais vous répondre bon d'abord
Emmanuel Macron quand vous avez
découvert Jean-Michel Blanquer Agnès
Buzin Muriel Pénicaud je pense que comme
moi vous étiez dans la télévision et
vous a dit qu'ils sont ces gens et puis
on les a découvert ils sont rentrés dans
la lumière ils étaient dans l'entourage
d'Emmanuel Macron personne ne les
connaissait ils sont devenus ils ont
acquis en notoriété à travers leurs
fonctions c'est pareil chez Marine Le
Pen Emmanuel Macron n'avait pas
communiqué son gouvernement Marine Le
Pen de communiquera pas son gouvernement
je pense je pense votre liste de nom il
y a des gens qui viennent d'ailleurs que
tu ressembles nationales mais il y aura
même une majorité de gens
nous espérons bien nous parlons avec des
gens de la gauche chevènementiste nous
parlons avec des gens vous savez elle a
dit 2ememains lui ou des gens qui sont
dans sa philosophie d'ailleurs
les gens aujourd'hui qui rencontre
Marine Le Pen les gens qui ont
rencontrés matin midi et soir je peux
vous dire que la question ce sera pas
celle du choix mais enfin c'est du
trop-plein nous avons aujourd'hui des
compétences bien entendu il n'y a pas un
jour
il n'y a pas un jour sans que nous ne
parlions à des personnalités ou de la
société civile ou du monde politique qui
ne soit pas des gens du rassemblement
national et qui est envie tout
simplement de nous aider à redresser la
France il y a des républicains des des
personnalités politiques des
républicains qui vous ont dit si Marine
des membres d'en marche vous ont aussi
contacté c'est il y a des gens qui ont
été proches d'Emmanuel Macron ou qui
aujourd'hui sont officiellement proches
des manuels Macron et qui considèrent
qu'une réélection d'Emmanuel Macron
serait probablement un drame je vais pas
vous donner elle est non parce que je ne
voudrais pas les générer eux-mêmes vous
serez candidats législatives
[Musique]
il y a peu de suspense sur le fait que
vous connaissez l'attachement que j'ai à
ma circonscription il y a peu de suspens
sur le fait que je ne le sois pas est-ce
que là il y aura des alliances avec les
républicains avec
Eric Zemmour avec Nicolas Dubois vous
savez j'ai toujours considéré des
candidatures communes nous on a toujours
considéré que nos candidatures étaient
des candidatures d'union elles sont des
candidatures d'union nationale pour
former une majorité présidentielle
autour de Marine Le Pen donc là encore
tous ceux qui seront d'accord avec nous
sur la méthode sur les propositions qui
sont les nôtres sont les bienvenus nous
on n'est pas des gens sectaires on ne
gouverne pas comme Emmanuel Macron avec
mckinzey et une bande de copains mais à
gauche et à droite c'est pas en même
temps façon rassemblement national non
parce que ça pas été en même temps avec
Emmanuel Macron a été ça a été le pire
de la gauche et le pire de la droite un
gouvernement d'union nationale vous
savez ça résonne un peu comme le Conseil
National de la Résistance ça résonne un
peu comme l'idée de d'unir des Français
de bonne volonté pour redresser le pays
[Musique]